(hissing)
- We're good, we're good, we're good.
- Ah, my leg!
(hinge creaking)
(upbeat music)
Welcome to BuzzFeed's
Running Out of Ideas,
the new show that you guys
have all been begging for.
What we did is took a
bunch of popular keywords
and put them on some dice.
Then we're gonna roll those dice
and whatever the combination
of words it lands on
is the title of our video.
So let's get to it.
I'm here with the team,
we're ready to roll the dice
and find ourselves a video.
- [Participant] Whoo!
- Ready, one, two, three.
(banging)
condom
bra
smash.
- [Participant] I like it.
- What the hell does that mean?
- What does that mean?
- [Participant] Sophie, you're a genius.
- [Participant] Look at that,
freeze it with a--
- Yeah, we could freeze it with
liquid nitrogen and smash it.
Bra made of 100 condoms.
Freeze it, smash it.
We could use colored condoms.
- [Participant] Condoms
I think would break.
- Flavored condoms?
- Yeah.
- As long as the condoms smash, we have
the 100 condom bra smash.
- Who's gonna try the bra on?
- You know, a lot of bras
are just out there for free.
- Okay. I think we've got a video guys.
- [All] Yeah.
(club music)
(camera shutters)
- The day has come.
It is time for 100 condom bra smash.
We're ready to kill it.
Kill the bra. And the internet.
(club music)
Ready?
Three!
Two!
One!
(club music)
That didn't do anything.
- [Participant] (laughs) No.
- That's bullshit.
(laughter)
That didn't totally go as planned.
But, this time we're gonna
try a different approach.
We're gonna dunk the bra in water first,
and then freeze it with
the liquid nitrogen,
see if that makes any
kind of a difference.
We don't know. We're just tryin' stuff.
We're winging it.
(laughter)
Flying by the seat of pants, or something,
whatever they say. That's
a thing they say, right?
(club music)
- That is frozen solid.
- Three...
Two...
One.
(club music)
- Now you can put it on the table.
(banging)
There you go. There you go!
Oh. Yeah!
That's perfect, there you go.
(club music)
- Well, 100 condom bra smash.
It's a video.
(club music)
- That's kind of neat.
- [Jordan] That was kind of boring.
(hinge creaking)